bon voila vous retirer un peu le bras
vers moi vers moi elle vit voilà très
bien pour peu plus haut qu'il vous plaît
voilà je suis 10,9 à la vie n'est pas
facile pour moi je dors même plutôt
retenir la chaîne et marquer mais mesure
sur mon carnet bon poser conçoit quoi
poser
posée voilà on ne sait pas trop sur
enfin françois ne partait pas on vient à
peine de commencer aller au travail
alors pour mettre 10 3 m 10 + 7 mètres
50 + 17 50 17 60
attention ce qu'est ce que tu fais
perché là où un travail passionnant si
on a la chance d'écouter julie si tu
veux tu tu peux prendre la place mais
moi je ne saurai jamais messi écoute
c'est pas difficile du tutu monte à ma
place tu suis les directives de monsieur
dix neuf devient assez simple et les
passionnants facile car la
piscine et
on assiste à tout à l'heure j'ai rien et
tutelle parce que parce que cotto base
des france ne tirez pas comme ça et ce
n'est rien monsieur du slam
à voir mademoiselle julie avoue est venu
remplacer françois à quelle merveille
pour moi bon alors tenez le bras
viennent en relais l'artolie très bien
parfait ne voulait plus
je suis fatigué
c'est passionnant du tout haut si je
tenais françois
julie au
vous avez peur d'une souris dans
facteurs je ne peux pas vous dire ce que
je fais mais je fais un travail
passionnant passionnant très mystérieux
aucune chance en salle rit alors parce
que moi des choses mystérieuses et neman
n'arrive jamais
écouté fekter si vous le désirez je vous
laisse ma place mais alors un petit
moment seulement je vous remercie julie
je vous refais voudrait ça
descende est descendu
merci
je reviens dans une minute
enfin parents commencer je fais les
calculs très précis reculer le bras peut
julie voilà
à ses voeux aux facteurs aprilia il ya
une instance était
je ne sais pas je me semble que les
calculs d'un déserté gens pourtant dans
le fonctionnement de mon cerveau
réceptionne elle
est une source d'hallucinations bombe
alors restons calmes où j'en étais à huy
84 m 20 - le dessus du banc plus hauts
toboggans plus hauts toboggans à wii /
la longueur de la plage à marée basse
c'est ça alors des crampes dans les bras
point trop mystérieux est ce assez
mystérieux
je vais descendre peut-être que ce sera
aussi mystérieux
bonjour facteur
à vous installer un grand filet pour
jouer au ballon c'est une excellente
idée qu on ne plaisante pas casey mears
est c'est sérieux c'est même très
sérieux ces scientifiques nous
mystérieux c'est dommage que je ma
tournée a construit je n'ai plus le
temps 1 mais si vous voulez je peux vous
remplacez tu sais c'est à regret casimir
tient alors tout à l'heure d'accord
merci quasi vous en faites pas je vous
garde votre place merci enfin facteur
prix raisonnable c'est bientôt terminé
et de mes wc mois kazimiya
ah ben si les mains fois qu'il faut que
je m'arrête je reprendrai de neige je
suis malade
merci casimir d'être resté là debout
sans bouger ce soleil en me rendant
service tag rendu service à l aller les
enfants du temps tiers à travers moi son
représentant le plus haut que je suis
fatigué le plus représentatif mais enfin
monsieur l'islam et mais quand ça passe
fils à la nouvelle n'est pas encore
officiellement je suis fatigué officiel
mais je vais reconstruire le jardin de
façon plus rationnelle et plus moderne
je vais faire des parkings pour les
patinettes des débats landreau
des volumes paysager et des espaces
verts
verts mais qu'est-ce qu'il est fatigué
c'est
sublime
n'est ce pas
écoutez je suis passé devant très
exactement les phares
s'allument et le schisme
ingénieux n'est ce pas mini lucidité
mais je peux partager vanuatu 7 quelle
perspective n'est pas mauvais que ce que
je vais faire et ne faisait pas de
bagages étaient
là lors mais non mais non il était
interdit de déposer des bagages dans le
jardin
monsieur cette caisse est lourde mais
moi j'en peux plus je dois je la mettre
à la consigne automatique
oui évidemment suivi la consigne est
automatique et où était la consigne
automatique n'est pas encore installée
je leur en attendant
bon je veux bien faire une exception
pour vous je veux banaliser un parking
provisoire
là
et
voilà
et n'oubliez pas que cette autorisation
est provisoire
dites moi
tous ces changements là c'est c'est
indispensable mais voyons grand soir il
faut vivre avec son temps et ne pas tout
regardé
ce paysage vide
qu'elle vite quelle place qu'elle
l'immensité sauvage n'est ce pas
c'est pour que les enfants qui jouent un
nom françois si les enfants ils jouent
cet espace mais plus ligne non mais on
vient de loin pour l'admirer c'est
curieux tout de même fait tout pour
faire plaisir à tout le monde et je
n'obtiens que d'être réclamations je
vous assure monsieur du soin que ça
n'est pas facile de rentrer dans mon dos
il faut s'adapter chers amis j'essaie de
sortir des sentiers battus je me
retrouvais seul accroché à la pointe du
progrès dont on entrevoit les bienfaits
du tout monsieur juste prix il faudrait
peut-être y regarder à deux fois on ne
peut pas déplacer un peu ce bond est la
perte acté c'est rapide elle nous penser
à la perspective
perspective la perspective
peut-être que je vais pouvoir monter sur
cette chaise mais pas du tout géré a mis
ce côté va être bouché nous y sommes et
où il part un grand mur lit sur lequel
on entrevoit une presque que je vais
peindre je vois déjà les motifs la mer
au fond un petit jardin de vin et au
beau milieu des jardins des trains bas
et peut-être un casque à casque tiens
pourquoi pas du neuf sur amis vous
devriez cadre vous aussi
vous avez une imagination fête de l'été
tu es vivant en intentions pures tenez
pour faire plaisir je vais construire et
c'est un autre mur il a
oui il faut vite que j'aille trouvaient
françois plat peut-être petit
mes chers amis
je vous ai tous réunis ici
pour mettre les choses au point
certains détails de mon plan ne semble
pas rencontré l'adhésion totale non ça
c'est de la folie pure
on se sent plus chez soi nous ils et les
enfants ne peuvent plus jouer dans le
jardin on peut plus vieux m'acheter bon
bout je ne peux même plus me préparais
mes sandwichs et on ne soit même plus
notre courrier elle vous ne vais plus
courrier parce que je ne peux plus
passer avec mes sacs postaux il faut
faire quelque chose pour moi bon mes
chers amis je vois que vous attendez une
fois de plus que j'ai une idée géniale
mais on va demander quelques suggestions
vous me direz ce que vous en pensez bon
alors
disons que nous allons mettre le kiosque
le kiosque ou non ne nous a
pas mal c'est très bien le vent a le bon
renom c'est pas le bon bon là la
louisière se veulent très bien
les ballons alors les ballons alors
joseph notes et les ballons
non non non non non pas par ici à là
c'est très bon sur dix membres déplore
me plaît je veux bien vous aider oui
mais comment mais c'est très facile
grâce à ma main magique je vous allez
voir très simple regardez vous voulez
leur kiosque là où il est bien attention
votre kiosque aux
attentions maintenant vous vouliez le
banc par là n'est ce pas petite malle
magique attention bombe
en lan casimir tu es vraiment un
collaborateur précieux tout à
disposition du jardin que je viens
d'inventer est installé d'un seul coup
c'est la preuve de manger ni ouais moi
cette indisposition me rappelle quelque
chose
pour vous
[Musique]